Bebe's we're playing this game called a
sake or die
where's that data it's nothing it down
how to play let's see oh my god what the
heck yet they still have until 3:00 a.m.
to unlock the direction part - okay so I
don't know anything about this game okay
space jump shifter rod in Iraq a
flashlight tap locks and unlocks
Hervieux backstory I'm in a room in that
the old spirits of the house off the
road actively seeking kill those who are
foolish enough to enter oh my god your
friends have dared you to enter the
house day and night I'm not wanting to
seem like a chicken like you you go for
it you know I mean you the spirit Scott
midnight you have until then to look
around from over gosh with the Headlee
at the house you remember the legend
also states that to safe zones are
placed in the house - just hide from the
spirits the legend is in fact true but
that that's cut I'm glad it's confirmed
one safe house upstairs one downstairs
each one has camera systems mm-hmm
look the camera has arrived to come for
you play game jack-in-the-box be in the
house play a tune it's fun interactive
before its house playing a house you can
find it by following the sound it makes
or by looking it was located sweet I
make it easy free there they send
something to chase after you've gotten
the opens stay away possible blah blah
but neutral to a safe zone turn on
flashlight make okay let's do this
and about what sake oh my god I'm in the
house okay so let me let me check out
this landscape real quick please don't
no no okay anything in here now this
huge have until midnight though
not only will I have to wait technically
what three minutes is every minute is an
hour so I do go three M right
okay that's fine okay where is the safe
zones
that they said there are we safe zones
okay huh what the hell why is this
that must be a SafeZone
canopy right now
so is this the Satan
I don't really understand are you now
there we go
am i okay okay I think I'm right
it's chair isn't so dark okay freakin
dark out here freaking dark I think I
just hang out Anna
okay okay wait where they see entrance
right there
my god oh my god
I don't see that happening
now if your hearing as I can't
here we go
it's coming well I met at left there's a
sensei
oh great
man okay
I don't know where it is
oh I see someone
never
where the heck is the jacket box there's
yeah I can that was a thing
and okay so it spirit coming it in nine
minutes
exactly just nine seconds so let's do
this great no there it is
what okay
well that's that game there so I said
you know thank you